[Music]
hey guys it's katie i'm the producer of
this recipe and this is carly hi she uh
is the food specialist who helped
develop this recipe so we're gonna give
you guys some tips today uh something
that you might wanna do is make this
vegan so carly how would we make this
recipe vegan so to make this recipe
vegan you're already almost all the way
there what you want to do is make sure
you're definitely using vegetable stock
in lieu of chicken stock and omitting
the chicken completely replacing it with
your favorite vegan protein of choice oh
great or you just you could have no
protein right or you could go no protein
absolutely awesome and then what's
something that you might want to look
out for like some tricky areas sure so
when you're whisking the flour into the
oil shallots and garlic you want to make
sure that you're really
making sure that you're breaking up any
clumps this is going to prevent you
getting any raw pieces of flour that go
uncooked and then my last question is if
you don't like coconut milk this doesn't
taste coconutty but if you wanted to use
something else
any dairy-free milk alternative of your
choice is going to work great here so if
you prefer almond milk that's going to
be a great option cashew milk etc um the
reason i chose coconut milk here was
because of the higher fat content which
is going to lend itself to a more
traditional really thick creamy alfredo
sauce yeah which this really does taste
like alfredo yeah it is really don't
skimp on the garlic don't skimp on the
black pepper and definitely add the
lemon juice it is it rounds out the
flavor you need that acid yeah you
really do okay great well we hope you
enjoy that recipe yeah good luck bye
[Music]
you